so J I don't even know where to start in
your in your car Emporium but as we as
we head into this room for example uh
past a sea of Bugattis but what are we
looking at here well these are American
cars from the 20s
duesenbergs uh Packard a little bit of
everything where do you find them where
do you Source your cars well you know if
you're into something there always other
people that are interested in it too you
know odd a lot of these guys are hermit
kind of guys and they they they've had a
car since it was new and they've kept
their whole life and a lot of them just
wanted to go to a good home you know so
I usually pay what what are we looking
at here okay well that was interesting
that's the last dusenberg made by the
dusenberg brothers and the guy I bought
it from bought it in 46 locked it in his
garage and I bought it in 2005 after he
passed away it the garage hadn't been
opened in like 60 years really and and
you know you found newspapers of
Japanese attack again and all these kind
of stories you know so and you still
drive all of these cars oh yeah they're
all on the road they drive them all yeah
this is this has caught my eye mainly
because it's the book of the Morgan the
book of the Morgan there one of these a
Morgan these are Morgan these Morgans
these two are Morgans yeah yeah
magnificent aesthetic cars well English
cars do English make good cars they do
well you know what I was find that
English make one of any
great you go Hey listen I need two more
ah damn I can't do it what was it
Churchill said about Americans that
they'll always come around to the right
decision of exhausting every other
potential right yeah exactly exactly so
what do we have what do we have here
well there's a little bit that's
Japanese those are mazas there triumphs
these are all Jaguars over here oh the
Jaguars yeah e time uh yeah those are e
type the the red e type look at that
yeah yeah absolutely magnificent good to
ask you I mean you come across a so easy
mannered do you ever like lose your
um well you know one time I actually
this kind of like a road rage Story one
day I'm in I'm in my car and I'm in an
old car I'm kind of going along so like
I behind me be be I go what I go go
around me go around me so I kind of pull
out as he passes me he gives me the
finger you know I what's that all about
he F you you know and I P up what's that
F you and I go let me guess what go 52
fat bald huh divorce let me guess your
kids hate you right you hate your job
when was your greatest day was it high
school and I'm just berading the guy and
then he starts crying and I go look I'm
sorry CU you're right you're right my my
kids hate me I said all right pull over
pull over so I get in his car I go look
I'm sorry I go no everything you said
was true I said well how old are your
kids he goes 9 and 11 I got two girls
and they don't they hate me I go look at
they like Taylor Swift he goes I love I
go well look I got on the show Wednesday
I say well don't you come Wednesday
bring your two kids is my guess okay I
go in the dresser I tell Taylor about
this the greatest gives him CD swag
talking to the girls like you say what
songs you like she couldn't have been
nicer just the most wonderful person
yeah she was really very kind very nice
and how was the guy after oh fine it was
you know he was an he was an okay he was
just a stressed guy he's in traffic here
in La it's bumper to bumper you know
he's got some awful job he's divorced
you know he says a little about Taylor
Swift that story as well well yeah and
what what do you make of the fact she's
now this billionaire I think it's
wonderful I mean breaking all records
beating Elvis Michael Jackson all them
yeah I think it's wonderful I think it's
great she's really she's deserves
everything and you know she's a really
nice person yes I met her once I thought
she was lovely you know you don't get
any sort of uh attitude or any no just
just a wonderful person in fact I met
her dad once at a one of the one of the
car AR here's a proper here's an English
car you would get a kick out of this is
a 1934 rolls P2 chassis we built the
body here but this has a beautiful this
has a 27 L Merlin aircraft engine in it
oh my God out of it you see this plaque
here in memory of Thomas J Lane junor
Corporal US Army fifth core of engineers
special Brigade died on Normandy Beach I
a friend of mine he's a big insurance
guy and uh his name is Tom Blair and
he's written a few political books and
things a nice guy and his dad was an
American and he went to join the British
we weren't in World War II yet he flew
he flew to Europe he met an English girl
he married her okay she got pregnant he
went off to normary Beach and he died on
June 6th and my friend Tom never met his
dad but he always liked his dad flew a
Spitfire so he always collected the
models and the planes and all that kind
of stuff so when I got this engine I I
dedicated this to him and his dad and uh
it was just cuz that's what these were
built for I mean you you take something
like where's this from miss engine this
is from a 1944 deavin mosquito which was
a yeah which was a a fighter plane and
you know to me those and you built all
this yeah we built it here but those
guys in England these 16 17 18 year old
men that flew these planes I mean this
kid I I I have this car too there's an
mg down there in 1938 he got it as a
gift for his parents are graduating
college uh he drove the air he drove the
mg to the Airfield there a picture of
him and his parents standing next to the
plane blown out of the sky like a week
later later and his parents kept the car
and Tom bought the
car you know that it was the same plane
that just added from yeah so that's why
I put this on there as sort of a tribute
amazing yeah kind what I mean this is
such a unique vehicle now what would
this be worth if you tried to sell this
well no it's again it's more money than
brains it doesn't make any sense what
would it be
worth I don't know we got quite a bit of
money into it you could probably get 6
700,000 for it maybe be nice to do but
it's quite fast it's quite reliable how
often do you drive this one oh I take it
out but you only get where where do you
go in these cars where you go on the
road I mean just around locally do you
go further or no well I mean you only
get about four miles per gallon and it's
a 60 gallon gas tank so it's like 150
bucks to fill with you got a fire fire
truck well that's another them that that
that was Warner Brothers lock truck that
was the fanciest fire truck you could
get Warner Brother part their lock truck
at the at the 1941 about 1949 or 50 they
donated it to U Burbank Airport they
used it when Burbank Airport was done
with they left it out at the end of the
Airfield as a wind break uh you know to
keep dust off the Runway then when 9/11
happened you couldn't have anything on a
Runway that somebody could hide behind
could be where you couldn't see them so
I saw them hooking it up to drag it off
and only had 11,000 mil on it cuz it
just used at Warner Brothers you know
just drive around around bird bank but
it was pretty far gone so I saw I said
Hey listen what you thinking I said we
take it to the junkyard I said we drop
it over here the guy goes yeah I don't
want to drive over the junkyard so I
gave it to me and then we fixed it up
beautiful absolutely
beautiful we got a it's a
tank that's a uh that's a British that's
a feret that was used in uh Northern
Ireland Saudi Arabia from about the late
40s up until oh the Desert Storm was
about the last time you saw those so
really but it's it's got a and it's
street legal don't tell me you drive
that out no I drive that in La yeah but
see it's got tires not tread see like in
Beverly Hills you use a 30 caliber when
you go down wait a go downtown you put
the 50 cal you don't drive that through
Beverly Hill I drive and you know
something people just get out of the way
people are so when you turn that turr
around they just they just back but did
the did the police stop you or no it's
legal it's street legal it's no it's
it's no bigger than a Porche
lengthwise I mean it weighs 4 tons and
it's got guns on it but other than that
it's
fine which is the car you most enjoy
driving well I like them all actually I
me is there one like real Heart Stopper
for you well I mean there I like the
steam cars any you know anything that
rolls explodes and makes
noise now what are you driving uh well
I'm going to take you to my little
vehicle in a moment all right uh you'll
be un surprised to hear it's it's rather
like its owner it's British and classy
oh all right
yeah so what do we we got some amazing
cars here
right what's this one here that's Gordon
Murray's first car who GM who built the
F1 the legendary that weighs 775 lb 147
horsepower what is it what make it's
well it's called the uh a rocket car
those he built those he built uh I think
about 50 one of those um they cost about
the same as a Porsche so most people
would rather have a Porsche but I would
rather have that light fast I mean it's
really a fantastic car yeah
amazing and that's the McLaren F1 that's
this one here yeah that's considered
probably about the most valuable car in
the world you can buy right about now
what what are these worth you know I
paid 800,000 for 98 and people thought
it was crazy but last offer I got was 20
mil so what oh yeah that's a one just
sold for 24 million yeah $220 million
they only they only Built 64 of them so
in the world yeah you sit in the sit in
the center yeah what do they like to
drive oh it's fabulous car to drive it's
really considered probably the it was
vter the best car that of the last
century but if that car alone is worth
$20 million how many have you got in
total there's 206 on the road cars yeah
yeah so I'm doing the mass here there a
lot of well they're not all worth 20
million no they're not but a lot of are
worth money right uh yeah yeah I guess
what what these are these are new
McLaren that's A1 McLaren that's a trse
see that's a Tesla plaid right that's my
everyday car the Tesla fabulous car you
you like Teslas wonderful car yeah Elon
Musk is a genius yes genius yeah you've
actually had him you've interviewed him
in here you know something he's a a lot
of geniuses are
dreamers he's a manufacturer I mean he's
an engineer at you know he came to he
ended this Garage in 2006 s with his
prototype electric Roadster and I oh
this is pretty cool and he says you know
Jay I'm going to build charging stations
all up and down the coast it'll be free
and you can pull it in charge I'm going
you know right like that'll happen but
he was smart enough to build the
infrastructure at the same time
everybody else who builds an electric
car where can I charge it oh you can
charge anywhere just plug it well no you
can't I mean he's the only the first one
to really get the things so no he he's a
genius and I went down to that you down
to SpaceX inred Texas well okay we
around he goes Jay what I want to do is
uh we want to have go to Mars and have a
rocket land on Mars every 3 days I said
well how you going to do that he goes
well come here and we go into this
Warehouse he's got jet in a thousand of
them you know the engines is tall tall
in this roof and they're ready to go and
I go okay and while you're talking to
them you know physicist Elon excuse me
the trajectory trajectory The Rock
oh right okay incredible oh yeah very
bright guy oh yeah so more importantly
you've got all your cars very I've got
mine oh very oh there yeah the four yeah
the ason Martin raped that's a repeat
yeah that's based on the laganda repeat
are you thinking James Bond when you
look at this little beauty uh you know
if I do a little Daniel Craig or maybe
probably connory actually huh what do
you think I was thinking more Terry
Thomas but yeah
yeah but yeah yeah you like asimon I do
like asimon you know asimon is one of
those uniquely British
Brands and it it it's the car that most
people need you a lot a lot people say
it's not a real sports car but it's a
real sports car it's also a luxury car
yes and that's what's great you've got
the Fantastic handling but you're not
getting kidney punched every time you go
there you know it's got the proper
leather and the proper stereo now
they're wonderfully buil cars I I like
well look you can have it 20 million all
right there you go thank you thank you
very much it's my it's my going right it
obviously not worth that but because
I've driven it right because you've
driven it massively increases the value
no that is the
value J it's been what a what a pleasure
pleasure a real to finally get in there
and to see it I I invited you 20 years
ago I I know I won't leave it 20 years
for next time but it's amazing well
thank you it's an absolute work of Love
isn't it well oh yeah it's fine it's
fine we have a good time brilliant thank
you for your time thank you guys